hello and welcome to this video playing
jibba jibba there was so nemo again i
hope i'm not blundering a maid in one
the second time that was pretty awful
and this is an interesting way of
playing this position try to play on the
queenside and it's not so easy for black
to generate activity there with the
bishop on g7 isn't doing all that much
and the knight on e7 is also a bit
misplaced yeah that's a radical way to
do it okay if I take it there is a form
that makes the move I mean this is
strategically terrible at five but it
might be technically okay yeah I cannot
take it so it's really not not so nice
okay
it is strategically terrible because it
weakens everything he five the kingside
is 6 and so on and normally we would
just take but there's a form that makes
it somewhat playable at least ok here
yeah just a ch3 Angus so if now I can
actually take so let's do it I mean if
why is nobody would grab that exchange
yeah tween to be one nice gotta four so
we probably have to do the same
you can never really go eform and grab
an exchange the black ink side will just
not beam will just be too too weak to
undefended wise animove
95
9595 we should be 5 into x h5 bishop a
100k 1
95 mmm
yeah why not looks like it's just good
Bishop D 197 s is too much hanging okay
doesn't he doesn't take him but that
means I can just keep keep the material
and be a pawn up in addition to the good
position they only have a weakness on c3
M
it's odd
so I can just take only five oops
and now how do we do that hmm
Bishop to Bishop e7 looks good Bishop h6
is also also good mmm
what C form yeah that's also not easy
for black to say the least
where do you go now Queen d6 Bishop f4
is a deadly pin and that's the
alternative after which I thought we
should be three years simple and good
let's see
just goes back okay
and it's go HOH five it's a temple at
Queen f6 am and I'm not meeting him
which is a little bit disappointing
because the position looked like there
should be a quick and knock out to avoid
the Queen trade when the position is
completely winning but I thought it
should be even better so this one for
route g5 check and then we should be too
it's octavian kettle tonight
it is badly placed
Vegas has to go age six otherwise I play
look at five takes or three okay yeah
it's it's okay
night has no squeeze it's really funny
the winning ideas just to push d45 I
have to check though after mm-hmm
taking this one yeah I don't really see
what it does
just want to winter when they f3 pawn
and then the night is just dropping it's
the easiest way to win this position
okay so let's have a look at them so we
had him that was fairly normal it should
be three and he went there five yeah it
is an okay move it seems I mean again
switch strategically it's dubious to
play this move but itself
it's probably just activity that that
helps the an IGBT to and yeah maybe
really a fall it's something that I was
not quite sure about I mean I have this
and I'm always able to take them but
that might be a position where black is
fine I mean this phone and he's got g5
and so on that it's possible no the
bishop when g7 is not a big issue at the
moment and he's got an easy game here
probably so Knight bTW - wasn't even the
best reaction and yeah maybe maybe I
have to consider a form I mean I didn't
really really really do yeah maybe I
have to do this move water him so that
after a possible f5
I have h3 or yeah this is actually
interesting because now I'm pressurizing
this pawn this is probably really
stronger yeah it is stronger so the way
it wins I went to h3 back and now I was
able to take yeah G takes has to be
played and should g5 yeah I thought I'm
just fine him the engine gives it a body
equal hmm no better for black
Quincy Sam I thought that would have
pretty good pressure against upon but
probably that's not true
27 is just giving me this one yeah I
mean this is not even possible due to
rookie 7 which I didn't see during the
game I was thinking I just recapture on
a1 and I mean this is a great
compensation but it's not better for
white it seems okay I can take it 7-7 so
this is why he went here yeah here white
should win by checkmate
d4 was better
now night has not squares it seems we go
here and probably meeting him no yeah
okay so this is probably not spoiling
anything but I could have won quicker
say did I make a mistake later on I
don't think so and nothing serious it's
interesting at this f5 it's not really
that bad so I have to play differently
here and not allow f5 in this particular
kind of situation where my bishop is
kind of a trouble interesting yeah
thanks a lot for watching